last point
satisfaction of students i don't see the
students as customers they are not
customers i'm responsible for their
education they are partner in the
educational process together with
faculty and management and we have an
ongoing continued continuation
discussions
i think that the majority are quite
satisfied with the process and i can
give you figures if it interests you
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court ventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders i am especially
excited for this one with professor ami
moyal the president of affect tel aviv
academic college of engineering
professor rami muyal has been president
of afeka tel aviv academic college of
engineering since 2014. before joining a
feka professor moyal was active in the
speech processing hi-tech industry for
15 years and held positions as vp
technology dev vice president business
dev and ceo of nsc natural speech
communication ltd welcome ami
professor ami moyal thank you so much
for joining me today at 20 minute
leaders how are you
fine thank you thank you for inviting me
we're going to have such an awesome
conversation because you're embodying
really the reason why i'm doing this
show under
sort of that that overarching theme of
of curiosity passion and and following
what you really need to be doing because
you're on a mission and
and right before we started this you
already left me with a sense of
inspiration that you're on you're on
your own mission and you're very much
convicted about it so i'm excited to
sort of unravel it from
being a ceo of a tech company to to
going into public service with education
today the president of the college of
engineering within a feka so a lot to
uncover i mean but but let's start high
level about sort of your own mission
what is sort of your purpose right now
what what are you doing
uh first of all again thank you for
inviting me to talk with you about my
passion and i'm using a lot of this word
the main strategic point of my work
today my mission actually it's not only
a work and i must i must say i also
enjoyed so it covers a lot of my
wishes
i'm implementing a major change in
engineering education as a whole i think
that the whole education continuum from
kindergarten to the academia must change
we are not adapting the education
continuum to the
new world to the changes in
in all aspects of life
so my my main focus today actually i'm
leading a process in the last five years
of
changing the educational process of
engineers
to follow two main aspects one is
industry needs the high-tech in israel
needs a different type of engineers not
only knowledge
an emphasis on skills like self-learning
critical thinking teamwork effective
communication skills written and spoken
and that's the output
in the inputs the students of today are
learning differently
i want them to learn with passion and
curiosity so we need to change the
frontal lecture to something that
encouraged curiosity and is more
hands-on so the input is different the
output is different we must adapt the
educational process and this is what we
are doing and if you want i can
elaborate more about the nature of the
change itself
so so we're definitely going to go there
but before that i just want to give
context a little bit to you and how you
got to become passionate about this
from being in the tech sector and
engineer yourself previously from the
army but um
going now to you know being a ceo of a
tech company what what made you even
start thinking about education as an
interesting
avenue for you to explore as a career
journey
first of all i think
that i was an education person
from the beginning even from the army 30
years ago i was a i was teaching in the
army itself i was a guy for technical uh
for technical technical people and i
enjoyed very much at the university i
was teaching
always
in addition to research so i think that
after the age of 14 40 i really
discovered what i want to do in life but
i brought all the experience i gained i
was the ceo of a high-tech company so i
gained a lot of managerial experience i
understand very much in technology
and then i shaped my view on how
engineers on the profile of the required
engineers so all three together
uh it was quite natural to me and it
came from my stomach not from my head a
little by little taking me to the place
that i'm today and you can hear from my
my tone of speech i'm quite happy about
what i'm doing
but you didn't go straight into college
of engineering you started looking at
sort of
um diversity in inclusion and allowing
underrepresented populations to have
equal access to education so that also
is a little bit different than the
traditional
sort of educated education path
that most people go on
yeah
you know i'm looking at israel on a
national level and i see that the
high-tech industry is now reaching to 10
of the workforce
and when you look at the 10 of the
workforce more than 80 percent of it are
located physically in tel aviv
by engineers that that are coming from
the center
and
this is something that i'm very
interested in there are arabs women
periphery that are not playing in the
game of the high tech in the sense of
social mobility and this is something
that is
interesting me for many years and you're
right i was
i had a position of a chairman of isaf
israeli
educational foundation
that raised money in the states and
gives scholarships to students in
periphery in order to use academic
degree as the basis for social mobility
so
the whole aspect of high-tech education
and social mobility is is more on a
broad view on a national level these are
the topics that interest me and we are
doing the same here with the feka
students from
the country
if students from all around the country
are coming to africa although we are
located in tel aviv we have students
from the north south jerusalem another
aspect any students will learn in africa
even if there is a lack
of finance to pay to tuition we are
organizing scholarship this is a
statement that i give to all my
management there'll be no situation that
the students is accepted with high level
of grades and will have no finance to to
finances uh
tuition secondly we are working with
teenagers in high school
before choosing the material the
matriculation path at the age of 14 we
are bringing thousands of pupils from
all around the country specific emphasis
on periphery
to visit afeka to see the science
technology and engineering
might be interesting and if it really
interests them
they should pursue their passion they
should learn engineering whenever they
want they it's not mandatory that
they'll come to africa they can go to
any academic institute that you want
it's more of an exposure to periphery
to understand science and technology
might be interesting and it is indeed
interesting but i understand that the
society should have lecturers and poems
and writers you should pursue your
passion but if you like it nobody should
uh
tell you that you cannot do it believe
in yourself and push it work hard this
is my incredible conclusion for my
career
i love it so
let's talk a little bit about passion
and curiosity for learning and how
you as an educator now
perceive that and how do you how do you
sort of guide
you know lecturers and professors to try
and
sort of capture that curiosity and
passion by students we started talking
about a little bit earlier i'd like to
go back to that yeah
first of all the underlying assumption
of the of the whole discussion is that
you can be excellent only in things that
you enjoy to do
if you are not enjoying something if you
are not enjoying something you will not
be excellent because you are obliged to
that's one that's the underlying thesis
of everything
meaning we need to build
engines of change for the students
to discover their passion and their
curiosity
once we have their their passion their
their energy their curiosity they will
be excellent because
in an academic institute and in general
in any educational system
the self learning of the students or the
people that's the key feature
we can give lectures we can give them
platform but if they don't have an
internal energy to pursue based on
curiosity
the the learning process we can do
nothing so
you can be excellent only if you enjoy
the process and now it is our duty to
build an enjoyable process
this new generation
doesn't like and don't learn by sitting
in class for eight hours they are
sleeping after 15 minutes that means
that we need to take to change pedagogy
to be interesting
for them to be awake working with energy
so
in the last five years we have
implemented dozens of courses in a
different pedagogy and i'll give you
examples for you to see
for example we have a course that i like
very much principle of sailing
engineering school principle of sailing
you learn electronics you learn
mechanics you learn green energy at the
end of the course we hire
10 or 12 small yachts
that the students in groups of four
are sailing
teamwork
excitement
handling with pressure
and a lot of joy so this is an example
of hands-on course with a lot of joy
uh
we got another course and another we got
dozens of courses but i'll give you
another example
we we have a course of
renewable energies
the course is performed at the southern
part of israel at
kibbutz a lot where they have pv
poto voltai uh
farms and the students are sleeping for
a week with their lecturers at the
kibbutz eating their sleeping they're
learning the full days so we are
implementing various methods of hands-on
we are learning outside outside of class
in
going to hospitals going to the industry
trying to give an experience of hands-on
rather than sitting in class and
listening for lecture so it's a mixture
of
frontal teaching together with hands-on
and many many courses
are starting by a half an hour the
introduction by the lecturers and then
divided to groups
putting projects on the table dividing
to teams and they are arguing
practicing teamwork self learning
discussion presentation and then they
are presenting their projects but we
know we believe
that every lecturer
should know what's the best pedagogy for
his course there's no one leading
pedagogy it can be flipped classes when
you read papers in english at home and
discuss at glass it can be projects it
can be outside we
built engines of change to support our
faculty to implement their passion so
it's my passion
the faculty passion the management
passion and the student passion if we
all work with passion we are going to be
definitely what i believe the best
engineering college in israel
wow
how do you do that at scale so how do
you you know it sounds like each of
these courses is is very difficult and i
think you started mentioning that you're
sort of creating agents of change and
you're you're giving autonomy and an
agency to lecturers to take their
passion and translate that to an act to
actionable
actions right to allow students to
experience it hands-on
as as a leader yourself how do you
create those agents of change what do
you need to do to sort of change that
mindset
first of all
organizations and people are reluctant
to implement change
reluctant right
organizations are
implementing changes only if there is an
imminent trend under a threat on the
organization
that's the classical of management so
the first stage about six years ago i
put on the table a strategic mission
the world is changing we must adapt we
should do it now not waiting for the
world to press us and then i convinced
the organization
secondly
we went to define and that was a major
change there was a question on on the on
the table asking all my management
what is the profile
of an engineer that is graduating a feka
that if you see all the skills you'll be
happy with yourself that you did an
excellent education system
and we defined all together it took us a
year
what is the ultimate profile of a
graduate of affect scientific knowledge
engineering knowledge
personal skills self-learning teamwork
engineering skills languages english
hebrew software three languages every
engineer must know ethical values
and broad knowledge you you cannot be
only an engineer that is focused on math
you must be aware of the global world
so once we all agreed on the graduate
profile actually i'm taking an
educational process and defining the
outputs i'm an engineer i'm a manager i
define the output together with my
management at that point once we reached
the agreement of what is the output the
required output our work was much easier
because there was a common agreement
what should be the output and then the
whole organization
targeted all activities towards the
outputs and then we begin to build by my
leading
engines of change
a center to promote learning working
with the students how to change your
learning a center for promoting teaching
working personally with a teacher when
you are implementing a major change you
need to communicate always mainly case
studies so internal communication unit
etc etc etc we had two years not easy at
all but the last three years the engines
of change are working and i see the
change and i believe that the change
will continue because the world around
us is changing so fast
organization cannot permit to himself to
stay at a certain point you need to
change constantly the constant change
will become the new normal
that's very difficult in the academia in
high tech everybody will understand me
in academia that hasn't changed 1000
years
my words five six years ago sounds like
uh somebody that is coming from another
world but
we did it we are there
how do you know what's working and
what's not working so in tech very easy
short feedback loops short feedback
cycles the market responds
in academia working with students
looking at something a little bit more
subjective like passion and curiosity
how do you measure that how do you
measure success of programs like the
ones that you're mentioning here
okay
there are various levels of estimation
when you implement such a change
once you implement it you want to define
and measure
and measure yourself on a yearly basis
the ultimate measure is the industry
remember we are educating engineers for
the industry
the main measure is if the industry is
hiring our graduates if they are
satisfied with them and they are paying
a proper salary and if they are working
in the high level positions meaning are
they accepted to the r d of the high
tech
and just a month ago we have completed
quite a lot so
you know from the from our discussion
you can understand that i'm measuring
everything
everything is azure data
just for a data to continue discussions
not uh not for not as a strict
measurement of management as a
celebration of data to to continue our
next next path because nobody is no
nobody knows at least i don't know where
higher education is leading where the
education system would be in 10 years we
must move forward measure adapt move
forward measure adapt this is how i'm
leading the organization in the
uncertainty around so
the main measure is the industry
if they hire yes they hire 97 percent of
our graduates are hired i have a major
problem they are working before they
complete the studies
yeah they are working
yeah
it's a problem because there is a need
of engineers in the high tech they take
them at the second or third year and
that's not very good because engineering
studies are very difficult you need you
need to work at least for the
full time
you need to study full time at the first
three years and nice positions r and d
various types of positions many of them
continue to master degree in various
institutes from from the position of the
output
that's the main measure but
we also
want to measure the progress in skills
during the process
so i nominated now a team
this is something that is not so well
known in the world is it's very hard to
to estimate the
or to measure or to evaluate the skills
so we have a group and we are trying a
solution by solution
doing pilots to see how we can evaluate
teamwork
self-learning effective communication
last point
satisfaction of students i don't see the
students as customers they are not
customers i'm responsible for their
education their partner in the
educational process together with
faculty and management and we have an
ongoing continued continuation
discussions i think that the majority
are quite satisfied with the process and
i can give you figures if it interests
you
eight years ago
we were able to accept
450 new students a year
and we had about
600 applications
last year
we doubled the number we are growing
we can accept 750 new students a year we
have
000 applications so
so
there is a demand from the side of the
market and there is a demand from the
side of the applicants these are the two
main factors that lead us to make the
change
incredible i mean such a such an
inspiring a not just um not just your
career but all but the way that you're
thinking about
sort of your and agents of change and
your own mission and and looking at the
students as partners and understanding
at the end and what it comes down to the
sort of
this fundamental
understanding that when people truly
enjoy our passion and are curious about
what they do then they strive for
excellency really sounds like that's
what pretty much you're you're embodying
with the vegas college of engineering so
thank you very very much
for the time and for the for the effort
and for joining me on 20 minute leaders
i appreciate it
thanks thank you it was my pleasure
thank you very much
you